ก็สวัสดีครับพี่เอ๋สวัสดีค่ะครู Arty
สวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนเรียนเยอากลับมาเจอกับ
ครัวตี้เจอกับครูพี่เอ๋ในช่องคอมพรีเฮน
สะโบไทยนะครับอยู่ด้านไหนด้านนี้
ด้านไหนโอเคข้างบนเอามาอยู่ข้างบนใช่ข้าง
บน
เป็นยังไงค่ะครู Arty วันนี้เจอกันวัน
อะไรคะวันนี้ที่เรามาเจอกันเนี่ยวันนี้
วันวันอังคารวันอังคาร
พอดีกำลังคิดอยู่อีกวันอะไรวันนี้วันอะไร
วันอังคารโอเควันอังคารวันที่เท่าไหร่คะ 5
วันอังคารวันนี้วันที่ 17 ครับ
วันที่ 17 ราคาให้ในแล้วเดือนอะไรคะอ้า
เดือนนี้เดือนสุด
อาภาคมเดือนพฤษภาคมปีค.ศอะไรคะที่คอยต.ค
2012  22 ครับหน้าอีกอัน 22 นะคะ Happy
ผชอะไรคะปีพ.ศ
2565 ครับ
แล้วตอนนี้เวลากี่โมงตอนนี้คิดใช่ไหมครับ
หน่ะเดี๋ยวกลัวตี้ดูเวลาก่อนอ้านี่ไงเวลา
เวลาฮ่าๆตีต้องคิดดีๆเพราะว่าตอนนี้คนไทย
เรียน 8:00 นด้วย
เวลาที่ไทยค่ะถ่ายนะคะ 20:00 นทุ่ม 155
นาที er5 ใส่ครับ
15 นาทีนะคะๆครับคอมพิวเตอร์มาใกล้ๆนะ
จะได้เขียนง่ายๆ
กี่พรรคอะตี้สบายดีนะคะ 5 สบายดีครับค่ะ
ถ้านักเรียนเป็นท่าเวลาซีรีส์นี้ต้องได้
เป็นซีรีส์ใช่ไหมคะอ่ะซีรีส์นี้เราจะไป
เที่ยวไหนมั้ยทีนี้ของตั้งตัวนี้ไปครู
Arty กับครูเอ๋จะพานักเรียนไปเที่ยว
ไปเที่ยวงั้นคลิปนี้เราก็จะพานักเรียนไป
เที่ยวอีกนะคะว้าวไหมเที่ยวคิดนี้กู
เอกภาพกูอะตี้ไปเที่ยวหา OK ว่าผู้เห็นจะ
พาไปเที่ยวที่ไหนคะวันนี้หากกว่าพี่อยาก
รู้และอยากดูจะไปไหนอะวันนี้ไปไหนใช่ไหม
แต่ผู้ a ขอแชร์สกรีนนะคะโอเคโอเคได้เลย
ครับนี่
ที่เห็นไหมคะอ้าตอนนี้เห็นแล้วครับ
สวัสดีเห็นน้าาจะพาไปเที่ยวนี่อ่า
มีประเทศไทยก่อน
ประเทศไทยของเรามาแล้วครับใครทวนทุกครั้ง
ครับครู Arty
คนไทยมีทั้งหมดกี่จังหวัดครับปกขวดที่ The
น่ากลัวที่ต้องคิดใหม่ก็มีทั้งหมดเอ่อก็
77 จังหวัดใช่ไหม
อ้าว 77 จังหวัดโอเคมี 77 จังหวัดนะคะที่
ครูเอ๋นะอยากจะรู้นะประเทศนักเรียนอ่ะนะ
ประเทศนักเรียนมีกี่จังหวัดค่าาและแต่บาง
ประเทศไม่เป็นจังหวัดอ้าวไม่เป็นจังหวัด
เหรอครับบางๆเหตุเรียกอะไรครับไม่ได้
เรียกไปยังอเมริกาจะเรียกรัฐขอ
ฮะโอเค 77 จังหวัดแล้วก็คลิปนี้ครูอตี้
กับครูเอ๋นี่
จะไปจังหวัดอะไรครับคลิปนี้อาทิตย์ไปที่
นี่ค่ะก็น่าไหนๆก็มิ
ทำไมของกูเอกเป็นแบบนี้กูเองว่าให้แล้ว
กันกล้วยเอาปากกาขีดเลยเอาอยู่ตรงไหน
ปากกาง่ายกว่านะคะตรงนี้ขับช้าใช่อ๋อ
นะตัวเล็กๆอ่ะกลัวตีพยายามอ่านอันนี้
จังหวัดปากใช่ไหมครับได้จังหวัดตาก
เขต 1 ตากจังหวัดตากสั้นๆคำเดียวทำเดียว
ตาก
ปากคู Arty เคยไปจังหวัดตากไหมคะขวดอี้
อี้ยังไม่เคยไปจังหวัดตากครับยังไม่เคย
เลยเหรอยังไม่เคยพวกที่เคยแดกขับรถผ่านจะ
พาไปแล้วกูไอ้ตี้มีรถอยู่ตรงนี้อ่ะจาก
กรุงเทพฯๆอ่ะอ่า
กรุงเทพครับขับรถแล้วก็ผ่านต่างเปิดที่
ขับรถไปเชียงใหม่อ่ะก็ต้องผ่านป่าแต่ไม่
หยุดเหรอคะไม่แวะไม่ได้แวะเลยยังไม่เคย
แวะที่ตากเลยครับอะติ๊ดต้องแวะ 5
ทำไม
ต้องแวะตอบอตี้จะไปเชียงใหม่สัก 5 วัน
เนี่ยกู Arty แวะอาจซักผ้าวันก่อนนะคะ
อ้าเชียงใหม่ 5 วันตากค่าวันถึง 10 วัน
เลยมันถูกควรตี้ที่ตากนะมีที่เที่ยวมากๆ
ก็คิดว่าครูอาติ๊ดต้องชอบว้าวมีอะไรบ้าง
ครับมีอะไรบ้างที่ขวดอี้น่าจะชอบครับเอา
อันนี้ก่อนเลยนะคะเปิดตัว F ไหนๆมีอยู่
ไหนเนี่ยอ่ะนี่ๆกูเอารูปมาจาก
เป็นรูปอะไรครับครัวที่เห็นเป็นรูปถนนแคป
ใช่ตรงนี้กู Arty เขาเรียกว่าเนินพิศวง
อ๋อเป็นเนินเป็นเนินที่เป็นแบบเนินคือ
เดี๋ยวกูอีกว่าตรงนี้ก็ได้ค่ะอ่าตรงนี้
อาจเป็นอันนี้ถ้าเราเห็นนะคะจะเป็นแบบนี้
ขอ
เรียกว่าเป็นเนินแนนนะคะ
แนนอะเวลาที่เราเห็นแบบนี้ครู Arty แล้ว
รถกูอะตี้อยู่ข้างบนตรงนี้ใช่ไหมคะครับ
ปกติน่ะท่านเนินแบบเนี้ยเราจอดรถที่นี่
แล้วแล้วไม่แล้วไม่มีเบรคมือครับรถต้องลง
มาข้างล่างใช่ไหมล่ะรถก็จะไหลลงลดลงมา
ข้างล่างเพราะว่าเป็นเดินรถก็ไหลลงมามัด
ตรงนี้สูงตรงหน้าต่ำอ๋อต้องไหลลงๆไหลจาก
ที่สูงลงมาที่ต่ำใช่เป็นเนินพิศวงแหละหมอ
รถอยู่ตรงนี้
แล้วรถไหลขึ้น
รถไหลขึ้นไม่ได้ไหลลงไหลขึ้น
จริงๆ
แปลกแปลกมากครับห้องเรามองเนี่ยข้างหน้า
เนี่ยสูงแฟนจอดรถพับรถไหลลงไปไหล่ขึ้นไม่
เคย
ขอ
ไล่ขึ้นได้ยังไงงงงงๆนะคะก็เลยก็เลยเรียบ
เนียนถึงพิศวงแต่ว่าเนินงงๆอุ้ยทำไมใหม่
เพิ่มไมไหลขึ้นทำไมรถไหลขึ้นแต่ถ้าจอดตรง
เนี้ยไม่ไม่ไหลลงท่อ
เนินพิศวง
อ้าเดี๋ยวคราวหน้าถ้ากลัวตีไปเชียงใหม่
ควรที่จะแวะไปแวะไปที่เนินพิศวงไปจอดรถ
หรือจอดรถแล้วก็แอปที่เราเช็คนะจอดรถแล้ว
ก็ปล่อยรถไหลอ่ารถจะไหล่ขึ้นหรือเปล่า
อะไรขึ้นหลายขึ้นใต้ชอบคิดไหลลงๆ
อัตถิอย่าลืมถ่ายวีดีโอนะคะโอเคได้ครับ
ได้ครับถ้ามีโอกาสไปหามิ้นท์เนินพิศวง
แล้วนะที่จังหวัดตากมีอะไรที่น่าสนใจครับ
นี่เลย
กว่าท่ออะไรครับเนี่ย
น้ำพุหน้าร้อนอ๋ออ๋อใช่ๆขวดอีเห็นมีน้ำมี
น้ำขึ้นมาอันนี้น้ำราคามีน้ำแล้วก็มีมี
ควันอีกเขาขาวๆใช่ไหมขนาดกว่านี้จะต้องมี
ควันอ่ะอันเนี้ยอันนี้เป็นน้ำนะครับ
น้ำสมิน้ำพุแล้วก็มีความอ๋อ
ในครับก็เป็นน้ำร้อนน้ำร้อนก็จะมีควัน
ขึ้นมาให้นะคะก็มีน้ำพุร้อน
คนไทยก็ชอบดูนะคะหา
น้ำพุร้อนดูได้อย่างเดียวเหรอครับดูน้ำพุ
อย่างเดียวหรอแค่ดูหรออ้าวตรงนี้ดูแต่ว่า
บางคนก็เอาไข่อ๋ออ้าเอาไข่ไปทำอะไรครับมี
แต่กราฟมีแบบนี้นะคะแล้วข้างในก็มีไข่ก
ไก่ขอ
มีไก่แล้วก็มีไข่เอาไข่ไก่ใส่บัตรหน้าลง
ไปโอเค
อ๋ออ๋อปิดต้มในบ่อน้ำพุใช่ไหมครับใช่ไข่
ออนเซ็นอ๋อเป็นใคร of  Saint นัก a และ
ที่ตรงนี้กินครูเอกครูเอกยังไม่เคยไปครู
อตี้ครับง่ายอันนี้นะกูเอกคิดจะไปเหมือน
กันนะคะเพราะว่ากูเอ๋ไปที่จังหวัดตาก
oh19 ปี
อ่อนนานมากแล้วพี่มิ้นท์ 2020
2997 นะคะไป 2 ครั้ง
ครับแป๊ะยังไม่ไปที่นี่หรอที่นี่ยังไม่
ได้ไปโอเค
อยากไปเดี๋ยวเราชั่วคุณครูหญิงครูฟ้าครู
เรียมหัดไปด้วยกันไปต้มไข่ไปต้มไข่ดิให้
กินไข่ต้มกัน
ส่วนนักเรียนด้วยไปค่ะเพราะว่ามีอันนี้
อยากไปอันนี้นี่หน้าที่นี่หน้านี้นี่
คืออะไรครับก็เป็นน้ำพุร้อนเหมือนกันค่ะ
อ๋อมีน้ำพุร้อนเมื่อกี้นี้ชื่ออะไรนะน้ำ
พุร้อนแม่กาษาอ๋อน้ำพุร้อนแม่กาษา
ส่วนตรงนี้ชื่ออาโลค่ะยาโปร่งคำรามชื่อ
ยาว
อะรอค่ะยาโป่งคำรามโอเคนะอยู่ใกล้ๆกันไหม
ครับอยู่ใกล้ๆกันไหมบ้านอยู่ที่เดียวกัน
อยู่ก็หาใช่ไหมใกล้ๆบริเวณกาษานาคาตกมี
น้ำตกแม่กาษานะคะนี้อ่าอันนี้เป็นน้ำตก
น้ำตกแม่กาษาแล้วน้ำตกอันนี้ร้อนด้วยไหม
ครับร้อนนี้คิดว่าล่ะกูเอกคิดว่าขอดูจาก
ตรงนี้ค่ะ
ดูจากอะไรนะหินออกมาน่าจะอุ่นๆร้อนๆ
เป็นน้ำอุ่นๆโอเคอ่าไปออนเซ็นได้เหมือน
กันใช่ไหมคะเขาก็เลยคอนเซ็นต้องมาที่นี่
โคโยตี้น้องมาที่นี่เท่านั้นห้ามลงไปใน
น้ำอันนั้นในน้ำตกแม่เอกสารลงไม่ได้ใช่
ไหมได้ๆน้ำตกและการสาวลงได้อ๋อ 5 แต่ว่า
ที่เป็นอันเสร็จแล้วดีกับร่างกายน่ะต้อง
ที่นี่อ๋อต้องมาที่เอ่อเดี๋ยวนะเอารองพญา
หงส์คำรามบทเห่กงคำรามนั่งเล่นชื่อ
aloe ค่ะยาโป่งคำราม
กว่าตีกับกูเองก็ปวดหัวฮัลโหลค่ะยาแปลว่า
ไม่ป่วยถ้าไม่ป่วยแข็งแรงอโรคยาแข็งแรง
มากถ้าเราค่ะยาแปลว่าไม่สบาย
อโรคยาก็คือแข่งคะแนนสบายดีแข็งแรงนะออก
ไป
อันนี่ที่นี่แหละครู Arty อ่ะดีนะคะเหรอ
ครับฟรีไม่ต้องจ่ายเงินหรอฟรีเสียเงินแต่
ว่าแต่ว่าแต่ว่าอะไรครับกูแอบติ้งต้องมี
ผู้หญิงผู้หญิงต้องมีผ้าถุงอ๋ออ๋อใส่ผ้า
ถุงผ้าถุงนะคะ
แบบนิเดี๋ยวกูอีกวาดให้อ่าผ้าถุงเหมือน
กระปอถ้าไม่มีผ้าถุงใส่กระโปรงได้ไหม
เผื่อนักเรียนนักเรียนบางคนไม่มีผ้าถุงทำ
ยังไงไม่เป็นไรเขามีให้เช่า 22 หมอนัดธขอ
ให้เช่าหน้าผู้หญิงนะคะผู้หญิงน่ะจะต้อง
ใส่ใส่แบบนี้
เขียนได้ไหมเนี่ยคุยอ่ะ
คุยจะเอาสีดำทำไมผัดสีแดง
แบบนี้ผ้าถุงครับใช่แบบนี้นะคะแล้วก็ลงไป
แช่น้ำ
ผู้ชายน่าจะมีผ้าถ้าเขาม้าอ้าถ้าเขามา
ราคาแล้วก็ลง
ลงไปที่
แค่น้ำที่นี่ทางนี้โอเคแต่เทปวัดถังมั้ย
ทางน้ำหรืออ่างเออถังน้ำก็ได้อ่างน้ำก็
ได้
ถ้าเป็นไม้เราน่าจะเรียกวัดถังเนาะอ่ะใช่
ครับตอนนี้เป็นแง
แล้วก็แชร์เราก็น้ำแข็งแรง
[เพลง]
aloe ค่ะยาเลยนะครับถ้าไม่ไม่มีผ้าถุงก็
เข้าหน้า 20 บาท 5 ถูกมาก 20 บาทถูกจะเอา
ไปเองดีกว่าฉันใจครับ
สำหรับที่นี่นะคะครูอาตี้ฟรีแต่ถ้าครู
Arty เนี่ยอยากจะช่วยก็เอาเงินใส่กล่อง
ออกบริการจากได้ใช่ไหมวะริจาคได้ไม่รู้
จักได้สั่งเขาบอกว่าสะอาดนี่ก็ไม่เคยไปนะ
ครับตัวเองมาครู Arty ไปแต่กูเองไม่เคยไป
ฮ่าๆอะอ้าวแล้วเอ๋ไปที่ไหนใช่มั้ยเลยไป
ที่ไหนมาแล้วบ้างครับพี่จังหวัดตากตัว a
ไปเดี๋ยวนะคะเลยไปที่ไหนบ้างครับคู๋ไปที
ลอซู
ทีลอซูขวดที่ยังไม่เคยไปทีลอซูโอะถ้ากูลา
จูนี่เป็นอะไรครับเป็นน้ำตกขอชื่อน้ำตก
น้ำตกชื่อทีรอซูโอเคคุยให้ดูรูปก่อนหน้า
มีรูปด้วยใช่ไหมครับกล้วยมีค่ะไหนครับไหน
ครับว้าวสวัสดีเห็นนะอ้าเห็นครับน้ำตก
ทีลอซูใหญ่มากเลยๆใหญ่มากมี 3 ชั้นมีชั้น
ที่ 1 ชั้นที่ 2 แล้วก็ชั้นที่ 3 ขวดตี
เห็นเห็นเหมือนน้ำตกไหลออกมาจากป่าใช่ไหม
ครับได้จากภูเขาตรงนั้นเป็นภูเขา 5 เป็น
ภูเขามีต้นไม้เยอะแยะเลยโอเคเน็ตก็จะไหล
ลงมาที่นี่หือนะคะ
อ๋ออ๋อมีสัตว์ชาติ
หาใครนะครับเอกไปที่นี่ค่ะกูอตตี้นะแต่
ว่าอะไรครับต้องบอกครูปาร์ตี้ก่อนว่าคุย
กับมาที่แผนที่ครับ
อาจาย์กรุงเทพฯใช่ไหมคะนั่งรถ
เอาเอาเอาทริปไหนทิปที่ 1 คลิปที่ 2 ดิอะ
ทิพย์ไหนก็ได้ครับเป็นยังไงครับจาก
กรุงเทพธานีคือที่หนึ่งอ้ะนั่งรถทัวร์ขอ
ขับแล้วก็ไปเช่ารถแต่สิ่งที่ 2 อ่ะมีรถรถ
รถตู้รถแวนรถตู้จากกรุงเทพฯไปเลย
เอาทิปรถตู้ครับคลิปรถตู้ใช่ก็ถ้าที่
ประตูเนี่ยก็จากกรุงเทพฯนะคะนักเรียนจาก
กรุงเทพน่ะแล้วเราก็สาขาจะไปตรงนี้เรา
ต้องไปที่ที่อำเภอหนึ่งชื่อแม่สอดอ๋ออ.
แม่สอดจากแม่สอดถึงจะลงมา
ไปที่น้ำตกทีลอซู
ลงมาตรงนี้ตรงนี้ชื่อว่าอุ้มผางของอยู่
อำเภออุ้มผาง
ค่ะที่อุ้มผางก็จะมีรีสอร์ทเราก็จะนอนที่
อุ้มผางอ๋อไปนอนที่อื่นหางก่อน
เพราะว่ากูอะตีจากจากตักกรุงเทพฯไปนานไหม
ครับใช้เวลานานไหมนานๆออกจากกรุงเทพตอน
เย็นน่ะถึงถึงจะแม่สอดตอนเช้าอ๋อกับน่า
รักนอนหลับนาง
ข้า
นอนหลับแล้วก็ค่อยไปตื่นตื่นเสร็จแล้วก็
ไปเดินเดินช้อปปิ้งให้คนขับรถนอนอ้าว
ตีนึกว่าตื่นแล้วก็เดินไปน้ำตกยังๆๆเทอญ
อาโต้โหยางยังไม่ถึงน้ำตกให้คนขับรถเมล์
ไปนอนเออครับนอนซักอ่า
เดี๋ยวก็นัดถึงประมาณปี
ตี 4 หรือตี 5 เนี่ยล่ะค่ะนี่ตี 4 หรือตี
5 แล้วก็ไปนอนที่โรงแรมในแม่สอดก่อนให้
คนขับรถนอนนะคะเราก็นอนอาจจะประมาณ 1
ชั่วโมง 2 ชั่วโมง 3 ชั่วโมง
ตื่นไปเดินเดินซื้อของหือประมาณซัก 9:00
น
9:00 นครับ 9:00 นก็ออกจากแม่สอดลงมาตรง
หน้าที่อุ้มผางโอเคลงมาชี่อุ้มผางแต่จาก
จากแม่สอดไปอุ้มผางเนี่ยถนนจะเป็นแบบนี้
คุยลบตรงนี้อ้าวถนนเป็นยังไงครับถนนตัวตน
พิศวงอีกนะครับ
ไม่พิศวงให้พี่ศวงแล้วนะเลย
[เสียงหัวเราะ]
ทำไมเหนื่อยทำไมถนนเหนื่อยถนนจะเป็นแบบ
นี้ขอ
เป็นภูเขาอ่ะค่ะครูอาจที่หัวใจใช่ๆเวลา
ขึ้นภูเขาก็จะวิ่งเลี้ยวไปเลี้ยวมาเลี้ยว
ไปเลี้ยวมา
เดี๋ยวโอ๊ยโค้ง
ขับถ้ากูอติควรที่ชอบขับรถไปเองใช่ไหมคะ
ใช่ครับว่าติโอเคมั้ยธาตุขับขึ้นแล้วก็ลง
แล้วก็เลี้ยวแล้วก็
สนุกดีครับสนุกดีหรือเปล่า
สนุกดีอ่าปาร์ตี้แบบนี้นะตรงเนี้ยะแล้ว
ตรงนี้ตกได้นะคะอ๋ออ้าเป็นเรียกว่าเป็น
เหวได้ไหมครับมีเห็นเหวภูเขาแล้วก็อ้อ
เอ่อออออออออภูเขา
ตรงนี้เป็นภูเขาใช่ไหมคะก็จะอ้อมแบบเนี้ย
อ๋ออ้อมไปวนรอบภูเขาใช่ไหมครับแบบนะครับ
แล้วก็ขึ้นไปอ๋อ
A1000 ป61คาน
1219 มั้งโอ้โห
1219 โค้งใช่ไหมเลี้ยว 1219 ครั้งหรือ
เรียกว่า 1219 โค้งค่ะโค้ง r  r  k
สวัสดีเงียบ
ๆ
ขับรถโค้งโค้งโค้งเหมือนกันอ้ะก็สนุกดี
แต่ถ้าขับนานๆเริ่มเมื่อยเริ่มเบื่อแล้ว
เดี๋ยวอีกแล้วเลี้ยวอีกแล้วเที่ยวอีกแล้ว
จ้าได้แล้วมันจะเวียนหัวค่ะเนื้อหาใจครับ
แล้วก็อาเจียนอาเจียนเรียกว่าเมาใช่ไหม
เมารถน้อยๆจะเมารถนะคะกูอันตีต้องมีมะนาว
มีมะนาวอุดมเอาไว้ดม
โอเคอันนี้นะทางที่จะไปนะคะอ่าแต่ตอนนี้
โอเคแล้วก็จะดีขึ้นเอามีหยุดได้มีกิน
อาหารได้แต่สมัยที่ครูเอไปน่ะไม่มีอะไรก็
โค้งคงโคนไปไม่มีที่หยุดไม่มีที่ให้แวะ
เลยใช่ไหมครับต้องขับตลอดเลยใช่ไหมค่อย
สมัยก่อนนะไปแล้วปวดฉี่นะกู Arty อ้าว
เหรอครับทำ
ไม่มีไม่มีห้องน้ำข้างทางไม่มีไม่มีตอน
คุยไปนะอ้าปี 2022 อุ้ยหมีนะคะโอเคอาจจะ
มีร้านอาหารมี coffee  shop มีมีอะไรเยอะ
ก่อนมาก่อนไม่มีหนังโป๊สนุกมากครับแล้วก็
พอไปปุ๊บเนี่ยไปท่าอุ้มผ่านก็จะมีรีสอร์ท
กูเองไม่มีรูปรีสอร์ทณรีสอร์ท S จะติดกับ
แม่น้ำ 5 ติดกับแม่น้ำว้าว
กูแอบไปนอนที่รีสอร์ทที่ติดกับแม่น้ำเป็น
บ้านไม้
เป็นแบบนี้
[เพลง]
แล้วก็เดินออกไปตรงนี้ก็เป็นแม่น้ำ
เป็นแม่น้ำอาหารเป็นแบบนี้
เป็นออกไปไปว่ายน้ำได้ครับในแม่น้ำไปว่าย
น้ำได้เว้นอาไม่ใช่หน้าดีนะครัชหน้าฝน
ห้ามจ่ายทำไมทำไมหน้าฝนห้ามครับทำไมล่ะ
เยอะอ๋อเสียหาไม่เจอเยอะมากน่ากลัวหลวง
พ่อลงไปจมน้ำก็จะผัดไปเลยใช่ไหมน้ำก็มี
เยอะน้ำก็ไหลเร็วมากมายน้ำไม่ทันห้ามลง
หน้าฝนนะร้อนค่ะหน้าร้อนน้ำนิดหน่อยขอ
ไปไปว่ายน้ำได้แต่อันหนึ่งที่ครู Arty
ต้องเอาไปก็คือสเปรย์
สเปรย์อะไรครับกันยุงค่ะยี่ห้อมียุงเค
มียุงมีมาลาเรียเยอะๆค่ะอ๋อ
ประเทศไทยมียุงเยอะๆที่นี่จะมีมาลาเรีย
อาทิตย์ต้องมีสเปรย์ทาต่ออ๋ออยู่นะคะ
ทีนี้ที่ครูเอ๋ไปโอ้โหไปทำแบบนี้ค่ะผัว
Arty ครูเอ๋ไปลงเรือยางอ่อนนี้หน้าเป็น
เรือยางแล้วก็มีชูชีพใส่ด้วยเสื้อชูชีพ
ด้วยใช่ครับเวลานั่งเรือ
นี่คุณเอกไปทำแบบนี้อันนี้ไม่ใช่คุยนะคะ
อ๋ออ๋อนั่งเรือยางรับเราเรียกว่าอะไรนะคะ
แบบนี้เรียกว่าล่องแก่งไหมครับนี่ฮ่องก่ง
เออเพราะว่าก้อนหินพวกเนี้ยนะคะนักเรียน
ก่อนสินเนี่ยเราเรียกไว้แก่งเนาะแห่งชาย
ครับเพราะว่ามาขวางมาขวางทางไว้เราก็ต้อง
ล่องไปล่องแก่ง
ครู Arty เคยไปล่องแก่งไหมคะอ่ะเคยครับ
วันที่เคยไปล่องแก่งชอบไหมค่ะ 5 ชอบครับ
ชอบสนุกๆแล้วก็เกลียดด้วยกูอ่ะก็ต้องไป
ที่นี่
ไปที่อุ้มผาง
ก็ไปร้องแก่งเขาก็จะโอเคพายเรือแล้วก็หลบ
ก้อนหินล่องแก่งแล้วก็เนี่ยค่ะจะไปเจอตรง
นี้ชื่อน้ำเป็นน้ำตกเล็กๆก่อนหน้ามีน้ำตก
ลงมาจากบนภูเขาเหมือนกันครับสนุกเล็กแล้ว
กันนี้
เขาเรียกทีลอเล
มีชื่อดูทีวีรอแล้วเจ๊ตอนตอนครูเอกไปกู
เองเรียกน้ำตกฝนตกอ๋ออ๋อน้ำตกฝนและเคน้ำ
ตกสายฝนน้ำตกฝนตกนะแต่ว่าคนที่นั่นเขา
เรียกทีลอเลมาขานอนตกทีลอเลต้องล่องแก่ง
ใช่ไหมครับถึงจะเห็นอันนี้ได้ต้องร้อง
canggu  Arty ไปยืนนี้ได้เราอาบน้ำได้
เหมือนอาบน้ำฝนเลยใช่ไหมครับให้กูอีกชอบ
ตรงเนื้อหาก็เลยเรียกว่าน้ำตกน้ำฝนใช่ไหม
เพราะว่าถ้ากู Arty ร้องแก่งไปเรื่อยๆค่ะ
มันจะร้อนใช่มั้ยอ๋อรณ์อะร้อนเสร็จแล้วพอ
มาตรงนี้แป๊ปอ่ะอ้วนเย็นสบายเลยครับ
[เพลง]
อ้าวมีอีกนะคะยังมีเวลาใช่ไหมคะถ้ายังมี
เวลาอีก 3 นาทีครับนี่พอคือตอนกูเองไปอ่ะ
กูเห็นไปตอนอ่ะครั้งแรกหน้าฝนครั้งที่ 2
เนี่ยหน้าร้อนขอร้องแก่งเนี่ย 1 วันแล้ว
ตอนหน้าฝนน่ะกูเห็นล่องแก่งแล้วก็หยุด
แล้วก็เดินขึ้นเดินลงเดินขึ้นเดินลงอีก 6
7 ชั่วโมงว้าว 7 ชั่วโมงนานมากไอน้ำตก
อ๋อ 7 ชั่วโมงเดินไปถึงน้ำตกพอดีรอสู้ใช่
วัดดีไม่ไปและเปิดตีนี่หารเดิน 7 ชั่วโมง
ไปนะร้อน
อ๋อกู Arty ไปหน้าร้อนน่ะครูอาทิตย์ขับรถ
มากใกล้ๆน้ำตกได้อ๋อไม่ต้องเดิน 7
ชั่วโมงได้ใช่ไหมครับโอเคได้อย่างเดิน 7
ชั่วโมงแล้วอ้าอ้าถ้าหน้าฝนตกนะฮะ
อ๋อ
รถไม่ได้
กะว่าจักร้องแก่งนะคะผุต้องเดินแบบนี้ค่ะ
กว่าตี้แต่นะมันจะบินทางที่แบบขึ้นขึ้น
ข้างบนลงข้างล่างขึ้นข้างบนลงข้างล่าง
ขึ้นข้างบนลงข้างล่างแบบเนี้ยก็เลยขับรถ
ไม่ได้ง่ายกูแต่ที่ขับได้ไหมอ่ะมันฉันมาก
เนี่ยจะบอกกันแบบเนี้ยแล้วก็ลงเราซึ่ง
แล้วก็ลงผมคิดแต่ตอนนี้น่าจะขับรถได้แล้ว
ได้นาๆไม่หมายถึงตัวอาร์ตี้ขับได้ในแบบ
เนี้ยอ๋อขับได้ครับเคยขับ
หาค่าเขาบอกว่าถ้าขับรถไม่เก่งนะกลับตอบ
ก็ไม่ขับมีรถมีคนคนที่ขับรถจริงๆนะเอ้อ
ไม่ต้องถอดเองเช่ารถไปได้โอเคนก็เพราะว่า
ขับรถต้องขึ้นอันนี้แล้วก็ลงแล้วก็ขึ้นนะ
คะแต่กูอีกอย่าให้กู Arty ไปน้ำตกทีเรา
สู่ดูที่รูปเนี่ยเท่านี้แต่ว่าถ้าเห็น
จริงๆกูอันที่จะแบบโคตรเหนื่อยมากใช่ไหม
ยาวมากสวยมากนะครับสวัสดีก็คิดคิดว่าจะไป
ครับอยากจะไป
ก็อาทิตย์ต้องไปสักครั้งนะคะโอเคครับวัน
นี้นักเลงก็รู้จักจังหวัด
ก็อาจคู๋พาไปแม่สอดแล้วก็อะไรนะแม่กาษา
อ่าน้ำตกแม่กาษาอ่าแล้วก็น้ำตกทีลอซูที่
อุ้มผ่านใช่ครับน่าตื่นเต้นอาไปได้เป็น
ล่องแก่งด้วยใช่ไหมครับลองแก่งด้วยแล้วก็
ไปเดินเดินขึ้นไปน้ำตกด้วยวะว้าวงั้น
คลิปนี้ก็หมดเวลาเลยใช่ครับหมดเวลาแล้ว
ครับเดี๋ยวเรากลับมาเจอกันใหม่คลิปหน้า
ครับควรที่พี่เอ๋ครูเอ๋จะพาไปเที่ยวที่
ไหนมาติดตามกันข่าวนะครับ
ไว้บายค่ะแค่หน้าคลิปนี้สวัสดีครับสวัสดี
ครับสวัสดีครับนักเรียนไป by  A
ม.ค